[MUSIC]
I want to make a baby
Ah, Bai-chan, how do you make animals?
But I wonder if that's a bad thing 'cause
today's adults and all of us humans were born that way
We were made by our papa We're just like other animals
It's been that way for a long time
4 Creatures have been living like this for thousands of years So
maybe that's why boys and girls are separated
Maybe I'm selfish but what do I do before I'm gone?  I want to leave something behind, but
I can only fight
with frankness.  Maybe
, when I found out about it, I was very happy,
so I felt sick,
I felt sick. Completely silly reproductive functions were discarded in the process of human evolution.
That
's what you usually think You're a
man and a woman It's a troublesome system that's necessary just to move Franks
That's it
Humans have abandoned the tendency to be dominated by emotions like
that.